-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
I'm gonna get to the news.
The White House invited
thousands of people to gather on
the South Lawn yesterday to
watch President Biden sign
the Respect for Marriage Act
into law, because nothing says
"you have my respect"
like hosting a party
and not letting anyone
into the house.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
President Biden has been venting
to friends and confidantes about
the media's focus on his age.
Said Biden, "Can you believe
this crap, Walter?
How about you, Zeke? Jedediah?
Oh, crap."
[ Laughter ]
"I am old."
President Biden today attended
the U.S.-Africa Business Forum,
but not before his aides
reminded him
several times --
regular handshakes.
[ Laughter ]
In a new documentary about
her tenure in Congress,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi is
shown talking about
former president Trump, and
says, "He's totally insane."
Wow, he is going to be so
furious when he definitely
watches that documentary on
Nancy Pelosi.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, Nancy -- I know her."
"Well, this will be fun.
My old friend Nancy.
There's a documentary."
[ Laughter ]
"I love my docs."
After being arrested earlier
in this week in the Bahamas,
disgraced cryptocurrency
exchange co-founder
Sam Bankman-Fried is reportedly
being held in
a prison notorious
for harsh conditions.
For one thing, no conditioner.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, North Dakota
Senator Kevin Cramer said that
he is not convinced that
former president Trump
is all in on running again
and added,
"Losing another election could
be very damaging to his pride,
not to mention
the Capitol building."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey, 32%
of Gen Z are likely to call in
sick at work
when they're feeling unwell,
which is shocking --
a Gen Z person
making a phone call.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
13% of Americans believe
that they are worse
than the average person
at recommending gift ideas.
Well, not me.
Nana loved her roller blades.
[ Laughter ]
We had a lot of discussion of
what the picture should be.
Mike Scollins, who wrote
the joke, and is --
I think I can say this --
a terrible person...
[ Laughter ]
...wanted the photo to be
a grandmother in a wheelchair
holding up a pair
of roller blades.
[ Laughter ]
I think the one we went with
actually kind of looks like
she knows what she's doing.
[ Laughter ]
Like, she looks scared like
she's seeing an old boyfriend.
[ Laughter ]
These are the kind of
discussions we have.
Now we'll have
a nice, uplifting holiday.
Hopefully the last joke is
holiday-themed
to sort of clear the palate.
I see you're checking to see
what it is, Baze,
and now you remember.
Let's watch. Oh, no.
And finally,
the adult website PornHub --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, the adult website
PornHub announced
yesterday that one of the most
popular search terms for 2022
was a type of Japanese anime.
"It's called hentai,"
said your son way too quickly.
[ Laughter ]
Merry Christmas.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We are off and running.